[Music]
hello I'm Sophie Shevardnadze for most
of us implanting electronics into
ourselves still sounds like something
out of the science fiction but not for
my guests
I guess believes that human body is
absolute without modern technologies my
guest today is performance artist
stellar stellar it's really great to
have you on our show so your performers
of performance art is actually blending
biological body with technology and
you're doing all kinds of exciting stuff
from pushing the boundaries and I read
you say on one hand that's all very
exciting on the other hand that you know
we should be careful so which one is it
are you embracing the future or does it
threaten you oh I'm neither utopian or
dystopian in my ideas I think the
problem with technology is how to manage
it new technologies generate unexpected
information new kinds of imaging
possibilities so we always extend out
sort of comprehension of the world what
a body is how our body operates what it
means to be human so for me technology
is is generally a plus not a minus but
just to really understand more about you
there's this inventor in Canada called
Steve man bio state so he's also
experimenting with merging keys body
with machinery for quite a while now but
he's more on his scientific yes side of
it like he's doing it for the sake of
science no you you're an artist not a
scientist what what you do right now is
it just a commentary to what's happening
or is it also advancing science in a way
yeah look you know I am only an artist
on the other hand I have a general
knowledge of engineering of medical
techno
oh geez because of my hands-on
experience with them I see these
projects as aesthetic gestures to new
possibilities I think that we shouldn't
consider them in any way scientific
research on the other hand usually my
projects involves state-of-the-art
technology so for example when my third
hand was first engineered it was
sophisticated and enough even though I'm
only an artist to be invited by the Jet
Propulsion lab in Pasadena and the
Johnson Space Center in Houston to
demonstrate the hand to the extra
vehicular activity group so although I'm
an artist only there is an interest in
how new technologies can further our
understanding of the body I'm just
trying to figure out where the general
public is at at the moment in terms of
understanding all of this because with
Steve Mann I know he ran in a trouble a
couple of times for instance when it was
trying to pass a metal detector
it was beating like crazy and the
customs officer got so scared that they
literally had to sort of you know reef
out some mechanical things out of his
body
when it comes to you or do you think a
little too far out for most of the
people at the moment or not really
well I mean that's very difficult to
evaluate you know I think new ideas new
philosophies and contemporary art
practice often can only be evaluated in
the near future it will not be fully
understood now so for example it took 10
years to find three surgeons and to get
funding to begin the construction of an
ear on my arm and the surgeons never
really understood that it was an art
project during the second surgery one
surgeon was overheard saying to the
other two surgeons well you know if this
is art we must be the artists we get to
your ear on your hand project and talk
through it in detail but before we get
that still want to talk a little bit
about the effects of you know Robert
ization of human bodies what effect do
you think this experimenting will have
on longevity I mean could the no
mechanical parts replacing biological
body parts do you think it could enable
us to live forever I mean this is
something that humanity has longed for
throughout its existence yeah well I
think the idea of immortality for
example I mean in the near future this
is not going to be possible having said
that if we are going to be able to 3d
print organs using living cells if we
can grow organs and parts of our body
using stem cell technology if we can
engineer prosthetic parts that can be
components of the human body then we
will have a situation where we need not
biologically die because we'll be able
to
continuously replace malfunctioning
parts of our body and actually if we can
engineer an artificial womb that can
bring to bear an embryo to a fetus to a
healthy child then your existence will
begin without birth because your body
will already be external and it and your
your your life will end without
biological death so how do you define
human existence without birth without
death that's interesting yeah and I
heard I read you saying that you just
talked about reproductive organs right
now where some fundamental tenets of our
existence maybe revaluated with
technology like functioning of heart or
reproductive organs that actually
require you to be a man or a woman I
have two questions how exactly would
that happen like why how will technology
remove the necessity of gender the
necessity not talking technically the
necessity of gender and it's fascinating
when you think about it and it all may
come true what you're saying but why
would we want to do that why would you
replace just beats fine or why would you
not want to be a man or a woman I know I
I think I think with when I talk about
the future I always talk about a
contestable future a future of
contingency in other words a future of
choice rather than of necessity where
you know some institution or some
government undertake some eugenic kind
of programs because what it means to be
human is is different for different
people and it's a value judgement about
enhancing your body I'm not so
convinced about transhumanism for
example because there's this idea that
new technologies will improve our bodies
now I think this is simplistic because
an improvement of your body is a value
judgement an improvement to you may not
be an improvement for me because like
this Hawk do you think it's just encoded
in us humans say that in our species
this drive to change and replace things
because I was speaking to Martine reads
I don't know if you know it some very
famous astrophysicist and he things that
evolution is just gonna turn us into
machines eventually you know since you
know we're coming up with stuff that is
more reliable and efficient that our
biological cells and sometimes I'm like
are we really digging our own graves
with this curiosity perhaps but uh but I
think what it means to be human is
perhaps not to remain human at all
because as humans we're very curious
creatures and we want to explore other
kinds of possibilities are the kinds of
bodies machine bodies other kinds of
biological bodies I mean I've always
been interested in comparative anatomy
so in evolution we see different kinds
of bodies that perceive the world in
different ways in other words one can
argue that an insect and animal a human
have different um veldt's you know
different kinds of worlds that they
experience you know we know that a dog
only sees in black and white we know
that a bat navigates in ultrasound we
know that a snake sensors infrared these
kinds of perceptual apparatus and
different kinds of biological and insect
like bodies experience the world in very
different ways and with many different
durations the lifespan of
of some creatures is only a day some
creatures live much longer than humans
for example so I kind of speculate that
a future body might be a biological body
that is increasingly machining and
machines that are increasingly
biological and they'll be this
combination but wouldn't that be just an
upgrade of human race and we wouldn't
just be humans the way we know us well
but you know the idea of what it is to
be human is a historical an evolutionary
construct you know so for example when
we were hominids and finally developed
bipedal locomotion two limbs become
manipulators and we can construct
artifacts instruments machines in other
words bipedal locomotion allowed us to
completely change what it means to to
develop as a as a human body and you
know even a couple of hundred years ago
the idea that you would have internal
components that were no longer a
biological parts would would have been
inconceivable you know now it's
acceptable that an amputee might have an
artificial arm that is a carbon-fiber
arm operated by servo motors connected
to the users nervous system so we accept
this now we accept the fact that the
body that you are born with may not be
the body that you died with you might in
the future have a face transplant you
might have an artificial heart certainly
people will have artificial joints
that's already happening so we still
think that they're human but this would
not have been the case several hundred
years ago we're gonna take a short break
right now when we're back we'll continue
talking to performance artists telluric
we're talking about what it's like to
implant what are technologies and our
bodies stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with stellar performance
artist seller in your project the the
very famous one ear on the arm first of
all can you this show us sure the
process of actually implanting that ear
in your arm yeah and then connecting
from what I understand it's still in a
process right I mean it was sort of
related and have has been fraught with
medical complications like I don't know
from where I read infections yeah so
don't you think by getting with really
sick because of outside interference
your body's trying to tell you something
I mean usually bodies resist something
when they understand that they don't
need it well you know I mean to do
anything is challenging and it's
sometimes risky and we can't really
generalize about this there was a
serious infection in the second surgery
when we planted a small microphone
inside the ear construct and I had wires
coming out of my arm and that didn't
help because they were in my arms for
about ten days testing the the
microphone but effectively at the end of
the second surgery the surgeon even
though he had a mask a surgical mask on
even though my arm was wrapped in
bandages with a partial plaster cast the
surgeon could speak to the ear
his voice was picked up and wirelessly
transmitted so it's plausible and the
idea is still the intention is still too
intimate enable the ear to
electronically augmented so if you're in
San Petersburg and Moscow and I'm in
London New York Paris wherever I am
wherever you are you'll be able to log
in and listen to what my ear is hearing
wherever you are wherever I am so
correct me if I'm wrong but that is an
exact replica right it's a shame
it's purely AI aesthetical why would you
go through that trouble I mean you could
have just asked the surgeon to implant a
chip that's a good question you know as
an artist I'm interested in the idea of
alternate anatomical architectures why
do we have only two years two eyes two
liter two arms four limbs so for example
I've performed with a third hand an
extended arm a virtual arm and I was
always intrigued about making a
prosthetic part of my body using my own
skin using my own cells so for example
the process for constructing this was to
implant as a biodegradable scaffold
which is porous and when this is
inserted beneath the skin when the skin
is suctioned over the scaffold over a
period of about six months you have
tissue in growth and vascularization
occurring in other words the cells in
your in your body grow into the scaffold
it grows its own blood supply so now
this is fully integrated as part of my
arm it's a living part of my arm but
what's interesting will be to
internet-enabled the year so this other
project that you had rewired remix yes
basically sort of outsource your body
senses to others right do I understand
the concept correctly from for as long
as we leave people want to communicate
and they do it through literature
through I don't know
painting then later on sale photography
is this how all this forms of a question
will evolve into like people tapping
directly into each other senses do you
think it will all come to that
it's not something that will happen
definitely but it's plausible and it's
possible I mean the rewired remix
performance for five days six hours
every day I could only see with the eyes
of someone in London I could only hear
with the ears of someone in New York but
my body was in Perth and anyone could
access my right arm through the
exoskeleton that I was wearing and
remotely moved my body so it was this
idea as you said of outsourcing my
senses my visual and acoustical sensors
to people in other bodies and sharing my
agency so people in other places were
controlling the movements of my arm so
the idea of a distributed body of an
extended mind this concept is really
something that's already happening you
know we all have wireless media we
communicate remotely I can see your face
on my telephone in Australia for example
when you're physically experimented it's
completely different the difference is
that you yourself experiencing it in a
more intense way so there is that that
difference but what I'm saying is that
these actions these performances are in
fact already happening in in in some way
or another so if you take that idea to
the max like this whole intent
interconnectedness right where people in
theory connect to your feet and vice
versa yeah that really just
you know grows into the whole species
becoming one with each other isn't it
that what all the yoga gurus and people
were telling us all this time that we're
actually one we're all in it well in a
kind of general sense but what we're
talking about here is physically machine
eclis electronically being connected to
each other by choice so for example you
can switch on switch off you can be
online you can be offline in fact now we
share two kinds of worlds we share
online worlds where we are distributed
interconnected and we still experience
offline worlds where we're private
biological individuals and this is
something that is happening all the time
and will continue to happen but in in
very different ways so for example
another possibility in the future is
that all technology will be invisible
because it will be inside your body with
microscale sensors with nano robots our
body becomes the host for the technology
technology now is existing external to
the body but in the future might exist
in nano scale inside the pen but the way
I see what you're describing technology
that is installed inside of your body
and you've been connected to the
Internet is a weakness inside of you
more severe than any other physical or
biological weakness because I mean if
I'm connected to internet anyone pretty
much you can at any point hack into
myself to such vulnerability well I mean
hacking your body is always possible and
especially anyone
with a chip in their body a simple chip
is vulnerable to being hacked and as we
have artificial hearts as we have
augmentations to our brain then that's
something that we have to manage but you
know that kind of an argument doesn't
negate experimenting with these things
because you know if you want to just be
a biological body then you will have no
no machines to assist you you'll have no
media devices to communicate with you'll
have no heating system still if I have
media devices and Internet is all around
me and I do that very often I choose to
cut myself off completely because I know
that there's no privacy in our world if
you talk on the phone if you you know go
online everything you're doing is being
watched and listened to ballistic shoes
to to you know to give up our privacy
for the sake of facility facilitating
our lives I feel like we already are
living in the Internet and not having
internet in us biologically is exactly
that choice when I want to switch myself
off I go yeah but if I have it in me
yeah but the problem is if you don't
want to have it and someone forces you
to have it that's the problem but people
will choose to have chips implanted to
have their cortical capacity expanded to
have an artificial heart to keep alive
so if we do internalize our technologies
if we have implanted chips or if we
expand our cortical capacity or decide
to have something like an artificial
heart in our bodies to stay alive we
still have to engineer them safely and
be able to manage them in
why people can't intervene externally
well that and also just to make sure
that our bodies and brains and minds can
cope with it because most of the
neuroscientists I talk to right now are
saying that with the amount of
information we have right now accessible
due to the internet we our brains are
just going crazy because it's too much
for it
we're not custom-made for this kind of
information so if if we're talking about
you know having a chip in our hat
constantly being upgraded and updated
with information but does it mean that
we're just all gonna be slightly insane
and couple of generations well again I
don't take a dystopian view about that
there may be advantages there's always
some disadvantages it depends on whether
a new technology is overall a benefit
and my personal experiments
I think suggest that our bodies can
manage being distributed being
fragmented having additional limbs to
perform with and I think that what
artists do best is speculate about
contestable futures possibilities that
can be experienced possibilities that
can be evaluated
sometimes appropriated most likely
discarded thank you so much for this
wonderful interview and good luck with
everything thank you very much thank you
thank you
[Music]
you